[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained my name is Caleb
Dendy and today I'm taking you through
part two of the learn the neiderhoff
series with me Caleb of course in the
first episode I started going over the
lines with Bishop e2 this is kind of
known as the more positional approach to
the knight or F of course there are some
sharp lines in it as well but all of the
lines that I covered in the first
episode sort of revolved around the move
793 for white and then white going head
and castling taking you know kind of the
classical positional approach to the
position trying to you know control
squares and things of that nature so
today I wanted to go over all those
lines that I didn't cover in the first
lecture mainly all of the lines were
white either delays castling kingside
or doesn't Castle kingside at all or
we'll see one deviation on move seven
that has recently well I guess semi
recently become popular thanks to the
world champion so let's jump into it
here of course this variation starts
with e4 c5 Knight f3 d6 d4 takes takes
Knight f6 Knight c3 and a6 entering the
knight ourf and once again we are
looking at the Bishop e2 lines the
positional approach now the move e5 is
the way to continue and in all of the
first episodes lines we were looking at
ideas of Knight b3 Bishop e7 and at some
point castles sometimes Queen b3 and
then castles but mainly castles
immediately now I wanted to look at a
few different things starting with this
move Bishop e3 so with Bishop e3 of
course point is not castling yet what's
the downside to playing Bishop e3 well
you're committing this Bishop to e3
fairly early on which means ideas of
playing f4 are a little bit less
threatening mainly because you want to
recapture with the bishop also ideas of
Bishop g5 are
of course a lot less threatening as well
because you've committed this Bishop to
e3 so the upside you don't commit to
castling the downside you do commit to
something with Bishop III meaning that
these two ideas are a little bit less
scary now as in the first lecture Bishop
III is sort of the signal to play the
move Bishop e6 because once again as I
said the move f4 is a lot less scary now
we can pretty comfortably capture on f4
and this Bishop has wasted some time
moving twice as we've seen previously
so Bishop e6 and now there are a few
ideas here white could definitely still
just Castle and then we transpose to the
lines that we looked at in the first
lecture with Knight be d7 and this is
all stuff that we've seen before
if white doesn't want to go for this he
has a couple different options here as
well namely in the move Knight d5 or the
move Queen d3 followed by 95 or as we'll
see in our main variation of this line
there is a pretty new idea
I believe introduced by Wesley so at an
Olympiad that revolves around playing
Age 4 before doing any of these things
so we're going to look at all of this
let's start with the most direct move
Knight d5 and immediately so white is
taking control of the d5 square without
castling which of course leaves the
option open for white to Castle
queenside at a later date this is sort
of the reason for not castling kingside
immediately now at first glance it looks
as though this pawn on e4 is hanging of
course tactically this doesn't work out
because the move Bishop d6 is going to
be quite strong this Bishop control c7
then I can hop in and white would win at
least in exchange on the a8 square so no
taking there just yet which is why the
move Knight beat the knight bt7
is the most common and I believe the
best just defending the b6 Square and
now unfortunately for white this is
going to be an actual problem on e4 so
the move Queen d3 is to be recommended
here of course you can actually achieve
this move this by a different order but
here black can still comfortably play
Knight bTW
seven and after 95 we get the same exact
position so queen d3 and now what's
going on here well Black has a few
options here black is sort of just
Castle and allow this night to stay here
for a moment or two longer but then you
might run into some things involving
this move c4 and the lines from here get
rather complicated I don't think they're
bad for black but there's no reason to
allow this sort of shenanigans when you
can just capture this piece immediately
with Bishop takes d5 no there's never
any C takes d5 to worry about now he
takes d5 and I think the next move by
black is pretty important just the move
rook c8 and with this rook on c8
white is actually gonna have some pretty
serious difficulties now following
through kind of honest promise to Castle
queenside so with this accurate move
order with bringing this rook to c8 now
after c4 defending this pun if white
doesn't play this way by the way be on
the lookout for the move Knight b6 when
you might never be able to play the move
c4 in fact you might have to capture
this guy which is pretty devastating
so c4 immediately castles by black and
now just castles by White's you know
obviously you're not castling queenside
into the move b5 anymore so castles by
white and then this is once again going
to be very very similar to ideas that
we've seen in the first lecture just
important to note that we need the
slightly accurate move order with rook
c8 to discourage any Queen side castles
and now we can go back to usual business
with the move like 98 and playing for
ideas of f5 okay so backing up there is
like I said a better move order here for
white introduced by Wesley so rather
than going for 95 or Queen d3
immediately the MU of h4 is actually a
really nice idea by White's to sort of
keep the pressure up now against h4
there's a very very common response and
many openings and here it makes sense as
simply the move age 5 meeting white on
the Kings side responding to age 4 with
h5 taking control of some light squares
and not allowing white to sort of gain a
ton of extra space or something like a
try for the move g4 now h5 obviously
comes with a pretty substantial downside
you might think that the downside is
that this pawn is going to be weak on h5
and while this sometimes can be true
it's pretty easily defended by the move
g6 rather the weakness is not the pawn
itself on h5 but the g5 square so it's
important to understand that h5 is
generally fine for black if this dark
squared Bishop has already moved however
if we compare a very similar position
and h4 here h5 might be less good
because now Bishop g5 would be very
playable in one turn rather than wasting
a tempo after Bishop e3 so we'll talk
about age 4 here a little bit later but
sticking with this Bishop e3 Bishop e6 h
4 now H 5 is fun because Bishop g5 is
very much a loss of tempo here now after
95 there is a little bit of difference
in the previous positions the move
Knight B to d7 was the move we were
looking at with the point being we are
challenging now in this e4 pawn but
thanks to h4 and h5 ninety five actually
came with a little bit of a threat so
who here understands what white was
threatening with h4 and h5 included and
what white should play in this position
who in the chat thinks they have it
who's got it here
what do we think
all right nobody knows nobody knows the
answer today artist says f4 that's not
going to be the idea here unfortunately
f4 I think would still run into this
move Knight takes e4 and it's all kind
of falling apart now for for white
actually with this pawn in age for
turning out to be a weakness in it on
its own I guess huh be a weakness itself
instead what white is threatening here
is to actually capture this Bishop on e7
and after Queen e7 now the move Bishop
g5 is going to be rather awkward once
again with this pawn on h5 the g5
squares horribly weakens and now black
desperately would like to play the move
h6
but it is highly highly illegal in this
case note that's in the initial line we
looked up 95 Knight bd7
if white tried something similar here
now the move aged six would be quite
strong and move like Bishop h4 would be
met immediately with g5 and all of a
sudden it's this pawn on e4 that is
going to suffer butts in this other line
it is very much relevance that Knight
take c7 and Bishop g5 exists in the
position I definitely have to be on the
lookout for this idea so for that reason
we just simply don't give white the
chance to capture on the e7 square and
play Bishop takes d5 first know after a
takes d5 Knight bd7 we have something
very very similar to the lines that
we've looked at
however notably white has not really
wasted a tempo on the move Queen d3
that's why it does seem like this line
it's a little bit of an improved version
of the first line we looked at today not
to worry though because black is still
doing just fine the move c4 is the most
common to support this guy over here and
now there are a couple games of course I
said Wesley so introduced this idea and
we are still following his game against
Marren both no Chooch
I think if I can try to pronounce his
name in that game Maron actually played
the move g6 and I think this is a little
bit too soft of a move if I can use that
terminology what do I mean by that it's
a nice solidifying move it's not a
positionally bad move by any means but
it's it's a little bit slow and the
reason for that is because the move
played in the other game that's reached
this position between re and tari and
here we go
papaya op Anu pop pop pop I mmm papi Oh
papi oh no that guy and they played the
move rook CJ
of course I do think that this is a
better move and the reason for that is
it's actually sort of indirectly making
some threats here if white plays
something like Knight d2 which is a
generally favorable move for white the
sanam b3 isn't perfectly placed and
white would very much like to play moves
like B 4 and C 5 well all of a sudden
look out the move B 5 might be coming on
the board and black would very much love
to rip open this C file for himself
which is why I think rook c8 is a really
nice move it's always going to be a
useful square for the rook and it gives
black this option of sort of playing the
move b5 you can compare this with the
game that Wesley so played which went g6
g3 b6 and now white very comfortably
played the move Knight d2 and black
plays the move a5 and so black does get
this sort of grip on the Queen side but
we'll see later in that game Wesley so
actually breaks through on the Kings
side and that's kind of the story of
this position after rook c8 in the game
of our antara he played to move a 4 to
sort of slow down these b5 ideas and
after this the move
a5 was played and I think this was the
right idea from poppy guano with a 5 so
at first glance it looks like black is
totally locking down the clean side and
it's true that he is and that is a great
positional gain for black to lock down
the Queen side like this means that he's
not going to have to worry
so much about B 4 and C 5 however there
is a second idea in the position for
white and so we'll see in this game that
it got rather complex once white started
going for this idea and I think that
whites might have been at an advantage
at some point because black wasn't
really adequately prepared to meet this
idea so what idea am I talking about
well we'll see in the game weight is
going to be very happy to play g3 and
castle and then white is actually
playing for this move f4 that we'll see
in the game so if you find yourself in
positions like these where you've locked
down the queenside
be on the lookout because your opponent
might start going for these ideas of f4
this is in fact I think the correct way
to play for white and we'll see it
didn't really work out for our an Atari
in this game with whites but it can be
very very dangerous so before we look at
our main game I started jump around but
we'll go back to Wesley so's game and
see how it can all go wrong sort of so
g6 g3 b 6 a 5 we see a similar lock on
the position to what we got in our
Antares game and now the move f4 by
Wesley so was played sort of immediately
and in general I looked at a lot of
different variations where white ends up
playing f4 and the correct response is
almost always to just take this guy off
the board what the movie takes f4 the
reason for that is this threat of
playing f5 turns out to be sort of
deadly in many many cases in Wesley Soze
game i suppo nat played clean c8 Wesley
castled we saw Knight c5 Kingi to rook
a7 Queen c2 Bishop back to d8 black
trying at all costs to avoid castling
into this attack and now after the move
f5 white is simply winning in this
position already so definitely these are
the threats to look out for and that's
why it's so important to be ready to
meet this move at 4 otherwise things
could go very very wrong for you ok so
backing on up in our game we had rook c8
a
of g6 g3 and now Knight c5 and castles
black castles as well and now with these
pieces sort of better placed this night
on c5 this knight on f6 black is
actually very much ready to meet the
move f4 even better than he was in the
case of the game of Wesley so once again
here the correct response is going to be
to take on f4 and after Bishop takes f4
there is a very nice idea of actually
playing the move and I f2 d7 and the
move f5 to get sort of a total lock on
the position on the light squares note
that you don't want to really be playing
this move sort of willy-nilly because
you do have to worry about Bishop takes
h5 sacrifices but in this case it is
going to be a good move probably though
black shouldn't play it unless he's
forced to and so a move like 95 is the
huge upside to taking on f4 you get this
square for your knight and then this is
just going to be a pleasant position for
black I think black is actually slightly
better after this exchange on f4 in the
game white did not play f4 instead
opting for King g2 and now black plays
this move Queen d7 which honestly was
not my favorite move of all time because
it does take away this Square from the
night I think something a little bit
more sensible would actually be to play
the move Knight F to d7 and if you play
f4 once again now the f4 is perfectly
playable but the move f5 is probably
even a little bit of an improvement and
we get a situation like the one I was
describing earlier where f5 is a useful
move to sort of take over on the Kings
side in the game Queen d7 and f3 was
actually the opponent's choice beasts or
efore it was played in the game by poppy
Yano and this is probably not a great
move after takes on e4 and you get some
complications but at the end of the day
very serious troubles could be coming
blacks way and and I think in fact are
coming blacks way in this position this
wasn't found in the game though but
important to note for not super
advisable in this position I much prefer
the ideas of moving the night out
the way and playing f5 here 98 is even a
perfectly fine move with the idea of f5
to to follow in this night can come back
so you for played in the game though and
then there were some complications here
I don't want to spend too much time on
this this night got into d3 and we have
just some position where black
sacrificed in exchange but it's not
really worse here with two ponds in a
very strong deep pond and this game was
eventually drawn so what are the key
points I want to point out here the
point is eight Bishop e3 is an idea is
to delay castling for a bit to keep some
ideas of queenside castling alive after
Bishop e6 h4 is a very nice inclusion by
white to not force h5 but induce h5
which is something that I'm actually
quite happy to do now after 95 we can't
play Knight d7 because white would take
on e7 and play Bishop g5 so we take on
d5 he takes d5 Knight bd7
c4 supports our D pawn rook c8 is a good
inclusion to make some threats of
playing b5 a4 to stop b5 was played in
the game and then after this a5 locks
down the position don't really want to
allow a5 by White's 92 and now from here
black activates his pieces and instead
of Queen d7 I like the plan of playing
Knight FD 7 or even 98 to g7 but mainly
with the idea of pushing f5 and getting
a lock on the King side and in the
center the important thing for black to
worry about is this move f4 you want to
be calculating the move f4 pretty much
on every turn
making sure you are well equipped to
meet this threat by white ready to jump
into e5 with the knight ready maybe to
play f5 to lock things down ready to
bring your bishop to f6 to control some
of these dark squares you just need to
be ready to meet f4 that's kind of the
only real danger that black faces in
this line ok
aside from that I really don't think
that white has too many threats in this
position and like I said given enough
time Fi and black can think about
pushing in the center but I can think
about activating this Bishop on f6 and
blacks
play shouldn't be too difficult to find
all right that is this eight Bishop e3
line that I wanted to talk about once
again
delaying cast link but committing the
bishop allowing Bishop e6 alright moving
on now I wanted to take a look at the
most aggressive variations I think in
this Bishop e2 line looking from the
black perspective we have of course the
starting moves in the night or if and I
hit c3 a6 Bishop e2 and now e5 Knight
back to b3 Bishop e7 and from here now
we've covered all of the lines involving
castling really early on we've covered
eight Bishop e3 and now it's time to
look at those scary terrifying pawn
moves on the Kings side that we've kind
of come to expect in this type of line
in the knight Orff so let's start with
the ones that don't make quite as much
sense here sorry I'm losing track of my
lines let me click this button really
quick okay
apologies here we go so the move f4 is
probably the one that makes the least
amount of sense for the same reasons as
in the first lecture f4 after Bishop e3
means we can take here and the bishop
wasted tempo but if f4 is played before
this Bishop moves that means we should
still have our Bishop back on c8 not yet
coming to e6 and because of that f5
isn't really a threat so we can Dooley
ignore this pawn and use the weakness on
the light squares to our advantage by
castling castling and then playing the
move b5 and going after the e4 pawn by
developing our Bishop along this
diagonal this is why f4 generally isn't
played unless this Bishop has all
come to e6 and this is going to hold
true here as well and this is just very
very similar to those positions in the
first lecture so f4 doesn't make the
most amount of sense now earlier on I
mentioned this move h4 in these lines
with Bishop III of course the difference
here is with h4 immediately Bishop e3
has not yet been committed so the move
h5 would actually be a bit of a mistake
here because Bishop g5 in one turn is
going to be a pretty desirable thing for
white to accomplish here rather than the
stutter step
so rather than play h5 you can simply
just develop with the move Bishop e6 now
what's the scary thing about playing
Bishop e6 well of course now we cannot
do this plan that I just mentioned
against f4 so h4 is actually going for a
slightly improved variation based on
playing f4 immediately here and I think
this is actually a slightly relevant
line now there are many things that
black can do here you can try to ignore
this F pawn and allow a push like f5 to
happen when your Bishop is going to
retreat but I think it makes the most
sense to still just take on f4 and after
Bishop takes f4 we have a situation here
where you can compare this position to
this position what's the difference
differences white got to put this pawn
on h4
for free now is that a bad thing for
white or a good thing for white kind of
remains to be seen of course the obvious
upside is that he's taking a bit more
space with this pawn on h4 attacking the
g5 square these ideas might come a bit
faster
the downside is he is losing a little
bit of control over the g4 square in the
g3 Square and this King is going to be a
little bit less comfortable castling
kingside so all in all I think it's a
pretty balanced trade-off and I think
blacks should still be doing fine here
there is one game in the database
between alexa anko and alexis Arana that
went with knight c6 and from here the
move Queen d3 was White's choice
the idea here is to prevent blacks
breaking move in the position which is
the move d5 this is sort of how black is
hoping to equalize against these ideas
ff4 with eat aches f4 so d5 is the idea
to equalize here white actually would
have a pretty good response with a move
queen g3 when all of a sudden things on
the kingside are looking a little bit
scary for black this might actually be
playable but there's no reason to allow
this black actually has a very good move
here and that move is night before and
now black white sort of says to say you
know okay
my Queens attacked I'll step back to d2
anyways and after Queen d2 of course the
move d5 comes to mind and this game
between Alex and ko and Serena continued
with a 3d four takes on b4 takes on c3
and now black regains this pawn on e4
and shouldn't ever really be worse
Queenie four and I def 641 Queen c8 and
they played some more moves in this game
but black really was in no danger at all
so that is the move Queen to d3 if white
tries to play a Queen d2 immediately
though avoiding this night before
nonsense now this is sort of the green
light to play the move d5 and there's a
game in the database here between two
slightly lower level players and that
game went with e5 and in the game 97 was
played which is a pretty bad move Nate
efore is actually going to be the best
move here and after it takes takes takes
takes once again black is just going to
have very active bishops and this is in
fact going to be a case where maybe
white would rather have this pawn back
on h2 rather than the Age 4 squares so
like I said always going to be a
trade-off with this H pawn okay so once
again with h4 we play Bishop e6 not h5
in this case f4 is the natural follow up
and just simply takes a knight c6 and go
for this idea of d5 to equalize either
after night before in the case of Queen
d3 or just directly in the case of Queen
- D - all right any questions on these
aggressive variations for white actually
sorry I forgot to cover the third
aggressive variation so we've looked at
f4 immediately which doesn't make sense
we've looked at h4 followed by f4 which
makes a bit of sense but black can
equalize now of course the move g4 sort
of deserves a look as well this is
actually the most common of these three
kind of aggressive variations and in
this case it does make sense for black
to stop the move g5 with the move h6 if
I move like this should be six g5 is
actually going to be a little bit
annoying with all of this space going to
white kind of directly so the move h6
comes to mind just to prevent this guy
from going any further and now if white
is sort of stubborn ly insisting with a
move like h4 well g g5 is still gonna be
hard to do we can just simply take you
can't take back with pawn obviously and
Bishop takes we can just develop and we
get to keep our pieces on there nice
little squares without really yielding
to a move like g5 a better move would be
Bishop e3 just getting developed again
after having forced h6 Bishop e6 and
rook g1 is a natural follow up to keep
these ideas alive but thankfully here
black doesn't have to do anything too
special just develop your pieces in this
case I think the c6 square makes a bit
more sense than the d7 square and the
reason for that is because we're a
little bit more interested in these
kinds of squares in this particular
variation because white is so very
clearly not castling kingside anymore
and we might someday want to sort of
launch an attack using these forward
most squares rather than these squares
over here so 96 I think makes sense and
after Knight d5 rook c8 is always a very
very natural move and it is here as well
also of course rook c8 is stepping out
of the threat of this should be six once
again once again if Knight takes e4
there should be six would be the
idea so rook c8 does make this a threat
and then in the game here between Lazar
Abruzzo and Batista and Vasily Ivanchuk
Bishop f3 was played to defend this pawn
we saw Bishop takes d5 he takes d5 now
95 was black's choice and black was
actually pretty significantly better in
this game and I'm and Chuck did go on to
win with this night landing on the c-4
square just uncomfortable position for
these bishops and these two moves are
actually looking a little bit silly
because White's attack is not really
coming with too much force on the Kings
side so this is g4 once again g4 h6 to
stop g5 and then just normal development
can kind of ensue developing out to c6
this start coming to c8 renewing this
threat we take off the knight on d5 and
then we just get our knight into some
very natural squares and it's going to
be a pretty standard play on the Queen
side as black here this is basically a
freak attack
yeah I mean I think having played the
night Orff in a ton of you know just
casual blitz games these days you're
gonna run into a lot of people like this
who just want to play g4 and try to come
kill you and so it is useful I think to
look at these lines even if they're not
the most common at high levels just as
an example the game continued 92 Knight
c4 and this truck actually maneuvered
all the way over to be 4 which was a bit
of a mistake a lot simpler was just
playing the move rook c8 and this is
going to be a very pleasant position for
black in fact black may just be winning
this pawn sort of by force in a lot of
cases for example c3 Queen a5 and this
guy is already very very difficult to
defend
Bishop f3 you run into the move efore
and things are are starting to look very
very nasty for for white just for
example this is not what you want to see
on the board if you're playing with the
white pieces
okay see it Rick see it would have been
simpler and black can just pressure this
d5 pawn black can play for space on the
queenside and once again maybe some
caution is gonna have to be exercised in
regards to this g4 pawn but it's not
really amounting to anything so any
questions on these g4 f4h four lines
where white sorta just tries to kill you
immediately in these Nider variations
yes good evening - mani any questions
last call
[Music]
okay well then I wanted to move on to
the last sort of ideas and they both
have different seventh moves but they
both have very very similar ideas at
heart so just to keep it all in order
let's start with the idea involving
Knight b3 still and then we'll move on
to night f3 but these two lines are
going to be pretty similar as we can see
so we have our opening moves be five now
Knight f3 is what we're gonna look at
next but we're going to still look at
night b3 here this should be seven and
now Bishop g5 is an interesting move to
take a look at and I say this line is
similar to the Knight f3 line because
both of these lines are going to revolve
around just trying to lock down the d5
square as we've seen in some cases with
things like Queen d3 before however this
is sort of white really really
committing to just going for this d5
square nothing else and whenever white
does do this as we've seen this Bishop
moves it's the clear to move our Bishop
out to e6 as well because f4 no longer
makes sense that is going to be the case
here and it's also going to be even more
important here because we want to
control d5 sort of immediately before
white gets a chance to sort of put a
lock on the position so Bishop e6 just
for example if you Castle to here you
might be running into some ideas of
playing even a four locking down b5 and
just moves like Bishop c4 to follow but
there should be six immediately is good
Bishop takes now Queen d3 is a the most
common move in the position you can kind
of combine this idea with 95 in many
many cases in this case it's less about
controlling the e4 pawn because
obviously the Stein has been removed and
more about giving white the option to to
Castle queenside here so Queen d3 first
makes a lot of sense and now the line
I'm actually going to recommend is a
little bit counterintuitive black can do
many things here including knight c6
including castles including bringing
this Bishop out to g5 but the line I
like the best
simply fish it back to e7 and what's the
point of this move well the point of
this move is you defend the d6 pawn so
after white castles Queen side for
example you can just play the move
Knight d7 and now this guy is well
defended now 95 can follow this is sort
of the main idea of the way black White
has been playing and we're just going to
capture on d5 Queen takes d5 and after
Queen c7 king b1 is natural black is
just gonna Castle a Kings side and we're
gonna have a typical opposite sides
castling position here where black is
going to be pushing on the Queen side
white is going to be pushing on the King
side and I think in this case blacks
play is actually coming a little bit
faster if white isn't careful you could
end up with a serious disadvantage here
with the white pieces for example h4
would be a natural move
but after b5 g 496 for example queen d3
a 5 in this position this is something
that's been reached a few times already
and it's clear that with a four coming
with tempo b 4 and a 3
coming soon to follow it's going to be
black with the faster play on the Queen
side here just for example if white got
greedy and tried to take on b5 this
would be pretty awful after a 4 and a 3
when these threats are becoming very
very difficult to stop for example B 3
would be a game and ur already yeah
nothing much to do here for white so
once again just to recap if white tries
this queenside castling business we're
just going to snap on d5 play Queen c7
and start pushing on the Queen side
after getting our King safe and sound
over here on g8 now white can try to be
a bit more clever rather than allowing
this trade I do think this is the
natural way to play for white getting
this Nate to defy the sort of the
purpose of this Bishop g5 move but white
can sort of
with something like g3 going for f4 but
blacks play is going to be pretty much
identical here at 4 b5 and so now if you
don't play Knight d5 soon you might
never play it after move like Knight b6
and if 95 we are pretty much transposing
with moves like Queen c7 and the same
ideas to follow for black if you don't
play this move something like king b1
well now Knight b6 is going to come on
the board and this I think is also going
to be pretty pleasant for the black
pieces okay so let's talk about if white
King side castles instead this is going
to be pretty similar to stuff we've
looked at in the first lecture with
ideas of Queen d3 and Bishop g5 to
follow but we just develop our Knight 9b
d7 and actually here I'm here
nope yeah this is the line okay sorry
mixed up my lines for a second but yeah
these are gonna be the similar ideas if
white isn't capturing on f6 we're just
gonna take back with the knight now and
life is going to be pretty simple here
for black FY tries to Castle kingside
and that is okay so that is the Bishop
g5 line and this is not the most popular
one because obviously it's it's not
really the most testing line and white
could end up in some danger if he does
go for these Korean side castling lines
now let's get to the earliest deviation
we can look at here and every line we've
looked at so far we've gone overnight b3
and I think we've just about covered all
the relevant variations after night b3
there might be an oddball line here
there that didn't get a specific mention
but hopefully you guys are feeling
comfortable with these ideas around 93
now now let's take a look at the move
Knight f3 which was championed by the
world champion a few years back looks
like 2017 was when he was first starting
to play this so let me swap over here
Knight f3
what is the idea of night f3 at first
glance this move sort of looks entirely
counterintuitive it is pretty severely
limiting whites options on the kingside
you know no more of this g4 h 4f for
business ever really happening with this
night in the way this night isn't ever
sort of limiting blacks play on the
queenside with nine a five ideas and
this this night just quite frankly looks
like it's blocking all of whites pieces
so why come back to f3 well it's
actually with the pretty deep idea of
getting this night to the e3 square in
some manner these are two of the most
common kind of roots for it to take and
of course from e3 it controls f5 and the
very very key square on d5 so this is
the deep idea behind night f3 however
will see that if black plays quickly the
whites night dream the White Nights
dream of getting to e3 might never
really be realized so we're gonna
develop the same way we have been Bishop
e7 Bishop g5 and this is of course the
similarity the line we just looked at
all about the d5 square still still
Bishop e6 will take on f6 take on f6 and
now King side castles of course
queenside castling ideas make a little
bit less sense here with this knight on
f3 once again I'm gonna recommend the
same type of play that we saw against
the queenside castle variations we're
just gonna drop this Bishop back to e7
with the idea of getting this night out
on the d7 square now if the move Knight
d5 this is sort of the idea so far and
in all of the games that have reached in
this position white is going ninety five
once again simply Knight d7 now Bishop
c4 makes a lot of sense for white just
to kind of support this Knight from
behind and here I very much like the
move rook c8 whenever possible I think
rook c8 hat is just always a good move
I kind of have yet to see a position
where I really wanted to play York c8
and but for some reason
bad it just really does seem to be good
whenever it looks natural to play it so
rick c8 always going to be a good move
one obviously not always but almost
always is a good idea in these positions
now in every game so far Queen e2 has
been the choice here and so far we're
following the likes of Fabiana Cara
wanna against Alexander Grichuk at team
back row against Irish chenko and yordan
van forest against Co Karev who is a
player I'm not totally familiar with and
believe it or not white has won all
three of those games so clearly we need
to be a little bit careful here with
black you know this idea is not so
superficial that white is not winning
any Kim's clearly the players with the
white piece is kind of know what to
doing here so there is sort of a split
here in six games that have reached this
position the most popular move is this
move Knight b6 when in every game Knight
takes b6 Queen takes b6 and either
Bishop b3 or takes on e6 that's been
played but I actually prefer the line
chosen by let's see which game are we
following here by Coker F which was the
move b5 against your Denton forest b5
forces this Bishop back to b3 directly
if this bishop comes back to d3 I think
black is quite happy to take on d5 so
Bishop b3 and now rather than trade this
knife for this night we get to plant
this Knight up here on the c5 square and
the reason I like this line a little bit
better is because now white is really
always going to be dealing with these
threats of Knight takes beef 9 takes B 3
in many cases he's also going to be
dealing with threats of Knight takes e4
in pretty much every position
additionally with this pawn on b5 in the
knight on c5 black is gonna have very
good control over the a 4 square which
is a break that white would very much
love to play in the game rook F to D 1
was played and black castled which makes
perfect sense now in the game the move
a4 was chosen and I think this actually
does hand the advantage over to black so
let's take a look at some of the ideas
here for black and actually I want to
ask the chat room what do you think
black should be playing in response to
the move
a4 what kind of moves are coming to mind
here keeping in mind our ideas with this
Knight on c5
oK we've got some ideas being tossed
around in the chat Knight takes b3 b4
has been mentioned it takes P 3 followed
by B 4 exchanging before take the bishop
queen a5 so you guys are on the right
track here there's actually a lot of
options available for black I think the
best one is actually one that you guys
have not mentioned so far believe it or
not and that thing I want to talk about
is trying to win this a for pawn
directly or if you're not winning the a
for pawn forcing some very serious
concessions by white so the move Knight
takes b3 I don't think it's bad it does
4 C takes b3 but now white is still
going to be getting an open file on the
AF files so for example if he takes a 4
why it's not even gonna take back with
the pawn but just take back with the
rook and the a6 pawn is going to be
rather difficult to defend
so rather than immediately taking on b3
I actually quite like taking on them on
the d5 square first and the reason for
this is white doesn't really have a
comfortable way to recapture this guy
if pawn takes now this is going to be
our go ahead to take on b3 and just play
the move Queen b6 and now there's no vk6
pawn that our opponent is going to get
we control the open file and this rook
looks a little bit silly sitting here on
d1 staring at its own pawn
now if rook takes d5 now I do think that
B takes a4 is actually a great move and
after Bishop takes a4 and Queen b6 still
all of a sudden this bishop is looking
like the worst piece of all time and
it's true that while white has a little
bit of pressure on the a6 pawn black can
more than make up for it with its with
his pressure on the Queen side pawns for
white as well for example here if c3 now
suddenly the move Queen b7 comes to mind
as well we are pressuring efore we are
more or less threatening to play the
move f5 directly if
like 91 for example trying once again to
desperately get to this big maneuver f5
immediately would be very intuitive and
very good for what for black and I think
this is going to be a better position
for for black in fact which leaves us
with lights White's third option of
Bishop takes d5 this might actually be
White's best try just abandoning the a4
pawn altogether and after c3 Queen c7
kind of returning to these ideas does
make some sense for white but it is
going to cost him a pawn to do it and so
I think black is doing just fine here as
well with white kind of having some
unclear compensation for this pawn he
does have a nice-looking bishop and this
Knight has a future but you know upon is
a pawn as they say okay that is all to
say that I don't think a4 is really the
best move here for white because black
does have these tactical ideas to sort
of get some kind of advantage in any
line that he chooses
so the question sort of remains what
happens if Knight II won of course this
is the kind of idea that white was going
for initially like I said rerouting this
piece over to the e3 Square is
definitely something on White's mind
here so how should black play in
response to this well I think it's still
actually just going to revolve around
making this bishop look like a dummy so
how can we do that here well we can do
that with the move a5 a5 is highlighting
the fact that this bishop does not have
too many squares
if white dares to capture on b5 well
look out after something like a 4 this
bishop is still quite stuck
for example takes takes takes takes and
it's going to be tough for white to sort
of keep this extra pawn with all of
these various weaknesses kind of
appearing in the position for example
the number one engine line goes 93 the
Knight takes e4 Queen takes a 4 Knight
to g5 and from here blacks gonna have a
very big Center and pressure on the
kingside as well and I think this is
more than enough compensation here for
for black to be perfectly happy okay so
once again if white kind of refers back
to normal we start playing these a five
a four ideas and this is going to be I
think pretty comfortable for black
activating this Bishop as well so these
ideas of night III aren't going to be
coming with as much power
now of course 92 would be a huge blunder
so white might even go for something
like g3 trying to develop this way and
now once again ideas of a4 start coming
to mind for black rook b8 to follow and
at some point black might take on d5 and
push B for opening up the Queen side in
his favor okay so any questions on this
Knight f3 line once again we have Knight
f3 followed by Bishop g5 this is sort of
the the point of these Knight f3 lines
is to take on f6 loosen up the d5 square
and go for these big maneuvers we have
takes takes castles and Bishop back to e
797 and rook c8 Queen e2 defending the
bishop and now I do like this line with
b5 and Knight c5 and black now just has
this latent pressure on the bishop on
the Queen side as well as White's enter
the game could continue like this a fort
was played by you or enforced and now
Bishop takes d5 would have been a
advantage for black after something like
takes and Knight takes a four and once
again the point is our opponent doesn't
really have time to go for stuff like 91
because we're gonna be advancing on the
Queen side so so quickly if you want to
be a little bit more conservative can
probably even start with the move rook
b8 and then go for this type of stuff as
well
for example c3 Bishop g5
Bishop back to c2 and something like a
five here and this is also pretty
sensible for black although I do like to
move a five immediately the most because
these Queen takes B five lines really
don't need too much for for white okay
yeah D six guarded by the bishop on e7
is safer than Alcatraz that is one way
to put it for sure okay
so that is pretty much all of the lines
in the Bishop e2 variation that I wanted
to cover so let's review I'm gonna try
to review pretty much everything here in
the next ten minutes just giving you
sort of the bullet point list thing that
you need to know so starting off we have
of course the Bishop e2 nine or five now
there are two moves here tonight b3 and
Knight f3 we just looked at night f3
so let's look back at night b3 we
developed Bishop e7 waiting to develop
Bishop e6 until white commits this
Bishop to e3
we have castles castles once again
waiting to develop this Bishop until
this Bishop comes to e3
there should be three Bishop e6 Queen d2
is the most common line we're just gonna
develop with 9b d7 with the ideas of b5
and knight Knight b6 to see for a4 stops
these ideas so now we switch tonight c5
ideas rook c8 Queen c7 rook F to D 8th
and 9th c5 the point being after takes
and takes white now has to choose
between playing 95 and going for these
types of positions with a bishop on d6
or just leaving this position sort of as
is when black can play c4 go for ideas
Bishop b4 and sort of try to paralyze
the white pieces okay that is this
Bishop e3 line the main main line with
Queen d2 we developed towards the Queen
side ideas of here ideas of nine c5
moving on we
have instead of Bishop III in this case
we move King h1 is a clever waiting move
and here Bishop e6 would be met by f4 b5
would be met by a 4 but I do like the
move b6 the point being you're not
allowing either of these moves to come
with force now after f3 Bishop d7 a4 to
try to lock things down on the Queen
side a4 is our signal to play the move
knight c6 and go for the beef 4 square
and now we of course are going for the
move
d5 ok breaking in the center and then
Black has no issues if black or white
plays a little bit differently with
Bishop e3 and f3 then we do take the
opportunity to play b5 + b4 and with
this structure we are happy to pressure
the center as well as activate our
bishop along g5 ok up next we have the
Queen d3 idea for whites with Queen d3
white is defending the e4 pawn and
preparing to play Knight d5 so Bishop e6
Bishop d2 is a clever idea to control
the a5 Square and APD 795 we take this
guy and play 98 going for counter play
on the Kings side you can play a 5 if
you want to stop the move Knight a5 and
be a bit safer but 98 going for f5
immediately I think is good enough for
black you activate on the Kings side
pushing in the center ok up next we have
the idea of night b3 castles castles
with 9 a4 so Bishop e3 we're developing
normally King h1 we are playing v6 in
developing this way a4 immediately
stopping b5 we are playing 96 once again
a 4 hour green light to go after the be
4 square and employ could continue with
something like f4 Knight B 4 B 6 it
should be 7 and breaking in the middle
with d5
as is the idea of night to be four and
this position is going to be fine for
black okay now let's look at the first
thing we looked at today eighth Bishop
III that's our green light to develop
this Bishop Bishop III age four to
provoke age five
now ninety five we have to take this guy
important move here rook c8 challenging
the C pawn on the C file a4 a5 Knight d2
and then here of course we have to be on
the lookout for the move f4 making sure
we have a good response and I think the
natural play for black comes after
Knight f d7 and expanding with the move
f5 just for example something like this
is very natural
this Knight can come back this Bishop
can drop back on east on g7 and play
would continue from there let's look at
the aggressive lines once again very
very briefly we have stuff like g4 we
just play h6 to guard this guy and then
develop normally we're not so worried
about g5 after the move age six and in
this game Ivan shook was much better and
would have been much better after rook
c8 when this pawn is difficult to defend
all right now back to these ideas we
just looked at Bishop g5 of course is
taking over the d5 square if white goes
four lines with castling queenside we're
not so worried we snatch them g5 play
Queen c7 and expand on the Queen side
and then lastly we just looked at these
ideas of Knight f3 and here we play the
same way developing with Bishop e7 and
night out to d7 and now we take over the
Queen side with b5 and Knight c5 with
pressure everywhere okay that is my five
minute review of the Bishop e2 night or
for these two hours of lectures that
I've done now stay tuned for next week
when we cover something different
entirely of course still in the knife
but I think this is it's for Bishop e2
hopefully you guys have a good grasp on
these
positions in these ideas for black in
these positions sometimes you expand on
the kingside with f5 sometimes you
expand on the queenside with B 5 and
always you try to keep a hold of the d5
square as is the NIE Dorf way if you're
watching live if we're gonna have a
tactics class on twitch directly after
this be sure to come check it out
if you're watching the YouTube video
that is it for tonight thank you so much
for joining me and I will see you next
time for chest openings explained
[Music]
[Applause]
you